faites moi un dussollier spécial jacky
aussi les mains faites-moi 1 roland
giraud alors trop café théâtre monsieur
faites moi un couffin n'ai pas d'enfants
dans ces conditions temples y faites moi
un boujenah je vous préviens monsieur je
ne le sert jamais sans accent mais
pourquoi est vivant et pour moi je
serais mort voilà monsieur par michel
boujenah bonsoir bonsoir
alors tu es venu en bateau la wii
qu'est-ce qui pilote le bateau le
capitaine a battu mais pas le capitaine
du bateau
ah non il vaut mieux pas tué le
propriétaire non plus ah bon ces
panneaux en bateau non mon bateau est
plus petits afin de capitaine
mon bateau à moi c'est moi le capitaine
mais c'est moins dangereux parce que le
bateau est beaucoup plus petit quand je
range mon bateau au port et bien qu'il
soit très petits en général ça dure au
moins une demi heure j'ai toujours tous
les types qui ont des bateaux au tour
qui me donne des conseils ce qui fait
que ça devient une catastrophe à une
date du mal avec les créneaux comme
beaucoup surtout parce qu'un bateau ça
bouge tout le temps vu et on n'a pas la
baie ça freine pas vu donc c'est l'enfer
car poser là ça va
pas encore mais ça commence à aller
mieux ah oui cela les j'ai arrêté le
théâtre ya trois semaines et j'en
pouvais plus en plus physiquement
bout du rouleau d'ailleurs ça se voyait
jeu j'avais même du mal à jouer quoi où
et en même temps c'était c'était une
aventure tellement forte du jury 185
fois dans l'année et c'était beaucoup
beaucoup de trop ça va tu as laissé ta
maison de saint paul de vence la salambo
oui hein c'est a fait part du choix
cette maison à peine tu l'as tu commence
déjà à l'aquitaine ont étrenné sur un
match ça fait deux ans je m'ai mais
avant quand je jouais des maisons
j'avais du mal à partir parce que je
savais que c'était fini qu'on est là
elle est là ça fait qu'elle est là elle
est pas loin
elle est là et je sais que si chez moi
et c'est quand tu as dit c'est la
première fois que je pose mes valises
oui ça y est la taton oui c'est chez moi
c'est vraiment chez moi c'est drôle
parce que je me souviens d'un copain qui
est venu au tout début quand j'ai
commencé vraiment besoin qui m'a dit la
location se termine comme alors cette
maison tu l'as rêvait tu l'a dessinée tu
en as surveiller la construction
oui et tu as dis je me suis saignée aux
quatre veines pour l'acheter we had a
coûté cher comme tout le monde ça c'est
pas important
tu as dit plutôt que de la vendre je
préférerais repeindre des appartements
nuitées jour ce que certains deux
appartenaient déjà les jours avoir déjà
fait donc c'est ce que c'est ah oui j'ai
déjà fait j'ai fait plein de trucs comme
ça avant ouais je n'aimerais pas et en
même temps si si pour la garder il faut
que je fasse des choses que j'aime pas
ouais ou une manière de travailler que
j'aime pas eh ben je la vendrai a quand
même oui il ya trop de gens qui ont
sacrifié leur vie à des choses comme ça
et dans mon métier j'ai vu des gens
comment dire avoir des besoins avec le
succès l'argent tous à avoir des besoins
puis tout d'un coup avoir un peu moins
de succès avoir les mêmes besoins et
commencer à faire n'importe quoi et a
plus travaillé comme il avait envie de
travailler
tout ça pour garder
les conséquences du succès je dirais
c'est à dire le pognon et et ça je
pourrais pas que cela serait le pire
pour toi comme chose à faire que je
supporterai pas vraiment tu dirais jeu
suivant la maison ce serait quoi
par exemple une émission de télévision
être animateur de télévision par exemple
mais ça risque quand même arriver parce
que ça m'arrivait parce que je pourrais
pas faire c'est impossible je suis trop
nul pour ça bah oui tu crois toi
ah oui oui je pourrais pas d'un ça se
regarde pas se voir oui non peut-être
justement contenu et que certains
dis-moi pourquoi saint paul de vence
alors je suis tombé amoureux parce que
c'est comment j'allais jouer à nice et
puis on m'a emmené déjeuner à la colombe
d'or et j'ai regardé en rouler et puis
je regardais cet endroit je disais
qu'est ce que c'est beau puis j'y suis
revenue
quinze jours après passer un week-end et
puis je dis tiens je vais répéter la
alors j'ai trouvé une salle de rupture à
nice et j'ai répété l'ange-gardien là
bas et puis j'ai commencé à connaître
des jambes je me suis senti bien c'est à
cinq minutes de la mer c'est à dix
minutes de l'aéroport
tout est prêt pas loin de paris c'était
simple et puis j'ai eu un coup de chance
formidable j'ai trouvé un endroit ce qui
est très rare j'ai eu un coup de chance
incroyable c'était c'est un coût qui
s'étaient disputés au parce qu'il ya des
gens fait que c'est fou parce que les
maisons c'est fou il ya des gens ils
deviennent fous en construisant des
maisons comme une merde il existait déjà
ah non non non
avant c'était des gens qui avaient le
terrain il devait confier une maison ils
se sont disputés sur les plans ils sont
tellement discret qu'ils ont divorcé
dis moi tu as pas été tenté d'acheter
une maison en tunisie pourquoi tu as
acheté à saint paul
maintenant chez moi c'est ici c'est quoi
le premier lieu pour toi qui est associé
à l'idée de vacances et quel endroit la
tunisie quel endroit
un endroit qui s'appelle crédit et à
côté de pas très loin de la goulette
on avait une espèce de petite maison de
vacances comme un peu tu sais comme les
cabanons près de marseille mais dans ce
genre là en fait avec une terrasse sur
la mer et tout et c'était le paradis
toutes les façons de comme tous les
comme tous les enfants qu'on a arraché
un lieu d'enfance où il était bien
j'essaye de reproduire partout les
sensations que j'avais dont je me
souviens de vacances en grèce où j'ai
passé mon temps et mes copains il me dit
mais tu es fou pression monte à dire ah
tiens ça c'est comme à tunis
tiens ça c'est le bleu de tunis à tiens
ça c'est le blanc tunis à tient
aujourd'hui me suis baigné comme à tunis
savez souvenir de grand amour de
vacances j'aime pas parler de ma vie
mais il ya une histoire qui est drôle
qui est arrivé c'est que kim a après
qu'image pas en parler maintenant parce
que ça fait ya prescription
c'est que mon premier flirt elle était
plus vieille que moi alors bon on s'est
embrassés je ne savais pas mais on s'est
débrouillé jeu c'est de faire comme je
voyais dans les films et puis mes frères
on m'avait raconté comment on faisait à
peu près et puis évidemment j'ai essayé
de
de lui enlever son soutien gorge et j'ai
jamais réussi
elle ne m'a jamais dit ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui ce genre situation m'arriver
je dirais écoute jean plectre au soutien
technique chaude au moins une paire de
ciseaux j'ai la rage
mais la jeune riche je n'arrivais pas je
savais c'était une sté un enfer j'ai
passé l'après-midi sur le soutien gorge
sur loup de la fermeture en plus est
comme ça m'a tellement traumatisée je
suis devenu un champion du monde de
scanner
maintenant tu séjour un tous les
soutiens gorge avec une main parce que
j'ai passé après après cette histoire
chaque fois je passais devant un magasin
de lingerie je regardais tous les
soutiens et je regardais comment ça
s'ouvre et j'essayais de mémoriser et
après c'est devenu un jeu chaque fois
que j'étais avec une fille jeu
j'essaie de toucher le soutien-gorge
derrière et je vous paierai l'ouverture
je dis ça c'est ça c'est la numéro 4 et
j'ouvrirai dix mois atteint les
souvenirs de chansons de 2 qui tomba qui
ont marqué t&t bah oui il y avait une
chanson comme mon père faisait tout le
temps tournait s'était tu me fais
tourner la tête ça mon manège à moi mon
manège à moi ça et puis et maintenant de
gilbert bécaud collège faire ça ça me
plaisait beaucoup
je m'étais souvent mais tu sais c'est
surtout des odeurs des moments la pêche
par exemple nous ont péché est
aujourd'hui à plus de poisson pour faire
ça on prenait des toiles de sacs de
pommes de terre en toile de jute beige
la comprenait de la mie de pain on
mettait ça depuis avec la friture qui
arrivait en face et on va installer son
entrée alors empêché à la bouteille
tu prends une bouteille comme comme ça
un peu mais comme ça mais incolore et tu
casses ici et tu mets un bouchon ici
sachez nas way et tu mets de l'eau de
mer et de latin et tu es tu là mais
c'était interdit et on mettait la
bouteille palois en la regardant à
surveiller on a tapé des petits mulet
comme ça et il fallait attraper des
mulets femelles pourquoi comme ça les
mâles arrive c'est par elle que chez
nous alors oui je vous rappelle qu'en
général les maldives
je sais pas comment mais pour les
poissons c'est comme ça c'était
premières vacances depuis combien de
temps
trois ans essayez dernière avant quand
même temps avant je pense avant deux ans
de quoi à peu près deux ans
mais c'est bon
en même temps c'est important les
vacances c'est une autre manière de
travailler je peux réfléchir je peux tu
nous as tu des trucs soit en bateau lors
ce moment oui un peu mais moi je suis
pas quelqu'un qui me gêne mémoire
incroyable
et puis c'est faire n'importe quoi les
vacances c'est ça qui est bien c'est
c'est dire j sommeil c'est dormir c'est
à dire j'ai sommeil et je veux pas
dormir et tu dors pas c'est sortir
jusqu'à 8 heures du matin c'est c'est
fumer des cigarettes parce que je peux
quand je joue le spectacle je fume
beaucoup moins c'est il ya une liberté
incroyable
le spectacle c'est une c'est une
contrainte c'est une discipline
infernale parce qu'on a parce que le
spectacle tous les jours c'est la
première ce que les gens qui viennent
voir ton spectre il n'était pas là la
veille ils s'entraîneront demain ça peut
arriver parce que mon qui vivent tous
les jours mais globalement bon alors ils
ont jamais vu le truc est pour eux si
t'es pas bien
même si tu as joué sans toi voilà tu
seras nul donc il faut que tu sois bien
tous les jours et tous les jours tu
arrives à un endroit beaucoup donné et
tapas de vie tes copains le samedi le
dimanche ce travail donc tu vois très
peu tes copains tu vois très peu les
gens mais c'est tellement génial en même
temps que bon ça va oui mais là non
médecin au moins je pourrai jamais
changé je pourrais jamais faire un autre
métier je pourrais c'est impensable
c'est impensable
j'aime trop ça et d'ailleurs c'est très
étrange
parce que je manque encore plus ça
qu'avant j'ai remarqué que
ça nous a manqué très vite
et puis et puis c'était plus en plus
important c'est peut-être le seul
endroit où je me sens pas donc on parle
la paix je suis vachement sérieux je
fais pas de blague parce que souvent
quand je fais des émissions de
télévision avant en tout cas je me
forçais à faire des blagues je me
forçais à faire des blagues parce que
j'avais l'impression que c'était comme
ça qu'il fallait les gens voulaient tu
pensais que les gens voulaient le voir
comme ça ouais et je suis pas très à
l'aise à la télévision il ya plein de
gens qui me disent ah tiens on vous a vu
une autre émission vous aviez pas l'air
à l'aise mais je ne suis pas à l'aise
parce que je suis pas chez moi parce que
je sais moi c'est une scène de théâtre
je sais pas moi j'étais bien là oui là
ça va sur la plage mais je le sois pas
il n'y a pas de caméra y'a pas un mec
que mon petit je constate questions
nouvelles têtes qui a parlé de camer be
mais je suis comme tout le monde ça veut
dire sortie de mon cadre je me mets à
jouer un personne a pu enrichir sa
disons que au début quand on visait par
exemple c'est encore de la comédie est
souvent rien je me suis amusée je
connaissais pas tous après ça m'amuse
beaucoup
je me rendais pas compte de ça et puis
petit à petit avec le temps la fraîcheur
de ça il a envie de faire ça comme c'est
pas mon métier je faisais ça pour
m'amuser
jallet la télé tout d'un coup j'étais
plus devant le magasin était dans la
vitrine ça me faisait rigoler mois au
bout d'un moment
bon ça arrêtez de me fasciner
et puis mon comme mon vrai métier c'est
pas ça et puis la télévision a beaucoup
changé après la télévision et s'il ya un
problème c'est qu'un faux si tu vas à la
télé en essayant comme ça de faire des
blagues de faire le bush n'a au bout
d'un moment tu tu totaux caricature oui
et là ça t'énerve soi quand on
caricature non j'aime bien comme
caricature ce que j'aime pas c'est qu'il
ya une fausse vision des gens tu vois
quand on réduit les gens c'est ce que la
télévision a vu leur voix la wii et et
et puis et puis c'est faux tu vois tu
peux pas savoir le nombre de gens qui
viennent pas me voir au spectacle
heureusement il y en a beaucoup qui
viennent me voir c'est pas un problème
mais le nombre de gens qui viennent pas
me voir parce qu'ils ont vu à la télé et
qui me disent ah ouais moi j'ai vu
boujenah vrai ça me plaît pas tu peux
pas savoir à quel spectacle tout le
temps exactement
tu peux pas sur le nombre de gens qui
viennent me voir au spectacle qui
viennent me voir après qu'ils me disent
ah je ne savais pas que c'était ça le
faisait parce que la télévision dans mon
cas à moi c'est pas le cas de tous les
comics ne restitue pas du tout mon
travail parce que moi je suis pas drôle
dans la vie je suis c'est des fois il dû
croiser des gens dans la rue ils te
disent ah ouais mais c'est moins drôle
qu'à la télé toi oh [ __ ] de témoins
drôle mais fait le cool ouais c'est le
coude
t'es pas un comique toi tu es un
raconteur puis j'aime bien
j'aime bien déconné mais c'est comme
dans la vie ça vient quand ça vient je
vais pas me forcer
c'est horrible de se forcer alors le
team jeudi mais je pas une machine
monsieur je sais pas - je me débrouille
à l'avoir longtemps ça me fait de la
peine j'aime pas qui dit ça ça fait
at-elle fait savoir
ouais c'est vraiment toi parce que tu
aimes bien aussi que les gens aiment
bien tu sais tu sais pas trop comment se
débrouiller avec ça c'est c'est
vachement compliqué et puis je te dis la
télévision a beaucoup changé aussi on
comment mais j'ai l'impression si tu
veux que que les artistes à la
télévision j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
moins à l'aise qu'avant je crois pas
être le seul
je crois que la télévision est devenue
une telle machine censée appris
énormément d'importance dans la vie des
gens maintenant on absolument avant tu
avais des gens qui disaient hier soir
j'ai vu un film j'ai lu un livre chez le
spectacle maintenant ils disent est ce
que tu as vu l'émission dechavanne ou
les mystères shippagan et même la
télévision fait parler d'elle ça veut
dire que les animateurs de télévision et
de l'arctique sur dans les journaux il
ya des magazines de plus en plus sur la
télévision
les comiques font des sketches sur la
télévision la télévision c'est devenu le
sujet d'ailleurs en bout de table
avant il y avait le père ouais et qu'il
donnait la soupe
maintenant il ya la télé à la place du
père il ya la télé et va demander à la
télé de servir à sous et les gens ils
mangent comme ça et je me demande quoi
ils font d'ailleurs ça a pris une allure
à mon temps c'est formidable c'est un
outil de communication génial et en même
temps ça en ferme tout le monde dans le
même système
ça fait peur et les moins en moins de
gens qui sont marginaux par rapport à la
télé sur ton sur ton bateau tu es là tu
es la tv la non tu vois par exemple une
autre chose qui me fait penser tu me
parlais de deux mois et de la télévision
il ya plein de gens qui que ça énerve
parce que des fois à la télé je parle de
tout et tu donnes ton avis sur tout et
ils disent ah mais celui-là il casse les
bons joueurs ils parlent dessus de tout
il s'intéresse il a un avis sur tout et
mais je trouve que c'est formidable
d'avoir d'être curieux ça veut pas dire
parce que j'ai envie de parler tous que
ce que je dis est intelligent je peux
dire des conneries j'en dis souvent le
problème c'est quand tu te retrouves
face d'un team qui te poses des
questions surtout tu répondre et que tu
lui journal ex tu t'intéresses si bien
de s'intéresser à tous j'ai pas envie
d'être un abruti qui dit ah non monsieur
ou en dehors du terrain je m'intéresse à
rien en quoi il ya une guerre en croatie
je sais pas ce que c'est la guinée a le
temps tu as trop exclusivement en
général pas de ça sousse et ça serait
bête qu'est ce que tu vas faire là ce
soir
maintenant la seule avoir tué dans une
boîte tu vas retourner sur ton bateau
regardez les sept étoiles qu'il faut
avoir vu avant ce soir tu peux te
raccrocher pour les équipes 1 je crois
pas que tu les verras ce soir les sept
étoiles
tout à l'heure on en a vu qu'une ouais
ils ont dit 2010 ben ouais et en tête
demain soir on verra
ouais ouais ya des liens il ya une
goutte qui tombe toujours qu'est ce que
je vais sortir potter et ouais je sais
pas je vais voilà c'est ça la nouvelle
bateau après oui monsieur georges sur
baulche y arrivera ah oui et non il ya
un type qui m'emmène ah bon alors rien
y'a un mec avec un petit bateau qui
m'emmène au bateau annoncé organisé à y
perdre peut tout arriver je suivais les
pointures de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu